hello everyone I hope you enjoyed my
previous video the one with Rosendo
Bolinas and the honey jar incident
because here is another one of Jeremy
Solomon's stories in this game he's
playing against eager Vasilyevich Ivanov
and yes that does sound like a very
strong Russian Grand Master and while he
is strong he is not a Russian Grand
Master he is a Canadian Grand Master and
how he became a Canadian Grand Master is
a very funny story in 1980 he was sent
to Havana Cuba by the Soviet delegation
to play in the Jose role kappa blanka
Memorial Tournament and after that
tournament finished he was returning
home but the plane had to made make an
emergency landing to refuel the plane
landed in Canada to refuel and here Igor
Ivanovich his chance and escaped he had
only the clothes he was wearing in a
small pocket what a pocket chess set and
while he was being chased by the KGB
agents he managed to acquire political
asylum in Canada and from 1980 he is a
Canadian citizen and the Canadian chess
grandmaster so this game takes place to
some 9 years after this event this is
1989 and he faces Jeremy Solman it's a
tournament in San Mateo in California
and as Jeremy Simmons says he go to a
city which you want to arrives to this
game in a near coma state he was so
drunk that he was practically laying
down on the board he couldn't even move
his hands when it was time to make his
move he barely lifted his hand made a
move in then the hand dropped back to
the table so quite an interesting
matchup
Jeremy Stillman against a very strong
Grandmaster and when I say very strong
ten years before this game in 1979 Igor
Ivanovich
Anatoly Karpov what a beautiful exchange
sacrifice so so quite a strong player in
this game even off has the white pieces
and he opens up with c4 the English
opening we have E 5 the King's English
variation Knight to c3 Knight to f6
and g3 now the two Knights variation
Bishop to b4 we have Bishop to G two
castles
d3 by ban of rook to e8 and Bishop to D
to c6 now Knight to f3
h6 ivanova castles and here black should
continue with something like d6 and it's
a perfectly fine position for black
Bishop to a5 is also an idea but here
someone says that yvonne of was so drunk
that she was actually considering
offering a mercy draw and that he really
couldn't concentrate on the game by what
to condition Ivana was in and he played
the d5 and he considered offering him a
draw but Ivana play tonight captures on
d5 and it was in this position that
Jeremy Stillman realized that he's
actually worse now it doesn't matter
what he does he will he will be worse if
he plays Bishop captures on b2 then
Knight captures on f6 and after Queen
captures Knight captures and d2 and
someone just lost a pawn and well it
doesn't matter how drunk you want to is
he could probably win this game being
upon up so after this Knight to d5
similarly played night chapters on d5 we
have C captures on d5 and the Bishop
characters on d2 by soman and it's in
this position that even off has to
continue with Knight captures and d2 and
after C characters on e5 simply Queen to
b3 and there is no way to defend the d5
pawn you could play Bishop to e6 but
then you lose the b7 pawn and if you if
you if you push if you push d4 then you
lose the b7 pawn by Bishop captures on
b7 Bishop captures Queen captures and
again you've lost a pawn so a better
position for white however you play it
but after Bishop captures on d2 if one
of actually played D captures on c6
and this is just bad for white this is
where it shows that he was simply too
intoxicated to think clearly Bishop to
a5 someone retreats the bishop so it
can't be captured and here we had a
knight captures on e5 here Ivana was
probably hoping for rook captures on e5
and here white would
white would in fact be okay after C
capture son b7 threatening to capture
the rook and bring up a queen so after
Bishop captures Bishop captures Knight
to d7 Bishop captures rook Queen
captures
and rook to c1 you would have a Sillman
would have two pieces for a rook but
Ivana would have three pawns extra so
white is definitely not worse here
probably somewhat even better but after
this Knight to e5 of course Sillman
doesn't capture the night he plays
Knight captures on c6 and here we had
night captors on c6 Beatrice and c6 and
Bishop captures on c6 Ivana is now
attacking both of Salman's rooks
but here comes Bishop to h3 attacking
the rook on f1 and the rook doesn't have
anywhere to go a one is covered by the
bishop on a5 here he plays Queen to a
for a better move the Queen to a4 would
have been to capture the rock by Bishop
captures an EA but after Queen captures
rook to c1 as there is no way you can
save the rook black doesn't even have to
capture it immediately he can play
something like Queen to a5 centralize
the Queen attack the pawn on b2 after
white defends this now you can capture
it after King captures attack the pawn I
need to for example pawn to e3 and now
Queen to d5 attacking the a to pawn and
also threatening Queen to h1 check
grabbing the h2 pawn black would be a
lot better here even if even if e1 have
played the best continuation but after
Bishop to h3 he played Queen to a for
some I don't know probably with a double
attack under rock on e8 and also maybe
to harass this Bishop on e5 but it
doesn't seem like a clear move someone
simply played rook captures on e2 we
have Queen to d1 now the rock and a8 is
still attacked and the rookin e2 is
attacked but Bishop captures an f1 now
the bishop is protecting the Oconee to
King characters and now comes the
unfortunate move 41 of rook to e1 check
here even off loses his Queen Queen
captures Bishop captures now Bishop
captures rook queen cap sorry first
Bishop captures an f2 kind of with a
tempo King captures and Queen captures
Bishop on a8
after rook to d1 Queen to D 5 D for
Queen captures rook to d2 and Queen to
d5 it is in this position that egorova
City which you want to resign the game
and the Jeremy summon says that it
was laughing as he resigned the game but
he was someone was not very happy with
this game as he does not consider this
to be a win against the Grandmaster
rather than he unfortunately had to face
a very drunk eager to run off so this
isn't the only instance Jeremy also
mentions one instance where Havana was
also playing against one player and he
also poured out a thermos bottle either
with coffee or with tea and he spilled
it all over himself and he started
jumping all around yelling how hot it
was and I've actually read a couple of
other stories about the Ravana where he
you know drops a rock or a piece due to
the fact that he was drunk so you know
seems like evil of a city which you want
to really really enjoy life in Canada so
do you have any experiences similar to
this have you ever played a chess game
while intoxicated or maybe you faced an
opponent who was drunk and how was the
experience I myself didn't play against
the drunk player but I did face a
hangover player a player who was
hangover and he was really nervous the
entire game he was higher rated than me
but he was really nervous and he his
face was still pink from all the alcohol
and he offered me a draw like I moved 15
I declined to draw and he was very
unhappy that I declined his draw for and
a couple of moves later he again offered
me a draw I declined it again because I
saw his position wasn't bad he was maybe
even better but I saw he was too nervous
and then he said to me during the game
which is not allowed he said and now I
will have to defeat you I said okay sure
no problem
and a couple moves later he blundered
and I won the game so not facing the
wrong opponent but he was clearly
hangover and probably waiting to have
some more alcohol but I got my win and
he probably got his alcohol that he was
looking for so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed the game and the story
a lot of stories by Jeremy summon like I
said he's a very successful author and I
am interested if you had any similar
experiences like this do share in the
comments I would like to thank Kozma
mastic look gran mason and and
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon and for those of
you wondering I will very soon upload
the subscribers video with their videos
and photos and I will assume start doing
subscribers games but I do have some
things to figure out first probably
probably in two weeks I will start
because I'm visiting Germany in a week
I'm going to but payment for a week so I
I'd feel bad if I started now and then
not to do it for a week and then
continue so better to do it when I get
back and then do it continuously so yeah
that's the game that's the update I
wanted you to have and like I said I
will see you soon